good morning Hank it's Sunday the other
day I was in an Apple store and someone
walked up to me and they said are you
John Green and I was like yes I am John
Green and the woman said I used to watch
your videos used to so Mike I don't have
a lot of time to film this video because
I got to go to Australia by the way
nerdfighters in Melbourne or Sydney if
you want to hang out with me and a bunch
of other nerdfighters check out the side
bar but Hank you and I just had two
extraordinary days at leakycon a Harry
Potter conference I was really inspired
to spend a couple days with people who
care about one another and making the
world more awesome so much and so
completely without irony like sometimes
in our hyper cynical world we forget
that it's okay to get enthusiastic about
things also another thing I like about
Harry Potter conferences when I was at
the bar someone dressed as Dumbledore
came up put his hand on my shoulder and
said what Dumbledore Harry well Hank I
don't need to tell you that I've been
waiting my whole life for Dumbledore to
buy me a drink and it happened so Inc
I'm not gonna keep talking anymore I'm
just going to show you some awesome that
we experienced at LeakyCon in the form
of wizard Rock
[Music]
to be a three
Oh
[Music]
say
yes
[Music]
and finally Hank I wrote an open letter
to the Twilight fandom dear Twilight
fandom call me when you can rock like
that Hank don't forget to be awesome and
the next time I see you I'll be in
Australia